so just strangers I have this happen to
me sometimes in like the music world but
just strangers come up to you and just
divulge the weirdest things to you
because of Curb Your Enthusiasm yes
so because kerb is this you know sort of
a commentary on social graces and the
lack thereof people come up to me and
they like to pitch shows to me so I did
this movie with Ray Romano we exchanged
numbers but we never we had never called
or texted each other so at the wrap
party Ray wasn't there but this guy was
like I've got a great story for curb I
said oh okay and so I don't know how
much I can say on daytime television but
so he said oh so he said so my wife and
I were having difficulty getting
pregnant so I had to go give a sperm
sample so I went to the doctor and there
was no good porn and I was having
trouble and I wasn't allowed to use
lubricant sellers and this is I've
literally been there this is like my
story
[Applause]
so far so good okay stories with all
these details and I and he's a stranger
never met her before money but a sperm
yes and go yeah so I said okay I got it
thank you and I will tell Larry and he
walked off and I looked down at my phone
and for some reason my phone had
pocket-dialed Ray Romano never talked to
on the phone before and I said oh my
gosh and I hung up and then I look to
see how long I had been connected to him
and I was like five minutes so oh and
you start panicking and I'm like blanked
i call ray and tell him and then my
friend was like don't don't call maybe
you didn't know was you just let it lie
and in the next morning like first to
get more a vibrato calls it he's like
did you call me in the middle of the
night and they said I did because the
guy with the sperm and he didn't have
Louie I didn't hear any of that but say
it again and slowly anyway cuz now he's
gonna use it
yeah but dial yes oh my gosh such a
friends episode with Monica Geller I
love it it's like it's I love that you
time Dan I've so been there best part of
today it's a process yeah
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this